dominic grabber was making uh the best
he could of an impossible wicket uh and
i mean i was also foreign for not for
two years but for five years um
and i i don't recall uh
more than just a couple of occasions for
really good reasons like serious illness
when tony blair
did not complete the calls to uh
appropriate head of government or in my
case i didn't complete the call to uh
the appropriate foreign minister what
this
it's much worse than a scandal it's kind
of rot
in the heart
of the of the government is doing is
also sucking
the life out of the government and
this is extraordinarily
diversionary of
all the kind of work that should be
being done
within government um and i know that uh
prime minister boris johnson is going to
the ukraine today with liz trust the
foreign secretary
and we heard dominic there saying oh
well you know he's been in the lead
on um trying to sort out
uh the ukraine
um but
across the world as you all know from uh
the researchers your people will have
done on foreign press
the united kingdom is a laughingstock
and johnson is not taken seriously at
all yes he's agreeing with the united
states
but
why has germany taken a completely
different approach to the ukraine why
isn't president macron uh taking it
a different view it's partly for their
own internal politics but
in the old days
a british prime minister would have had
a very good fist
at leading the rest of the
of europe certainly
and
pushing the united states president
along and it hasn't happened at all they
take no notice on him
i'm intrigued to know your take on
one of the points i was discussing with
the deputy prime minister former foreign
secretary um just like you and um i'd
made the point that this should have
been a phone call yesterday between
boris johnson and putin he said that
these schedules are moved all the time
and it's absolutely nothing to read into
that just because he was in the chamber
talking about sue gray you know it can
happen another time is that a reasonable
response
well um they're not moved all the time
like this i mean this was a big deal it
was a particularly big deal
for bryce johnson to have his breast
people announce
that uh he johnson was talking not just
to a head of government but to a head of
state in in uh
vladimir putin
um it shows
further evidence if you like of sort of
uh congenital systemic
chaos in downing street i mean
didn't for somebody think about the fact
that if they were going to have a call
with
putin it might be a good idea not to
schedule it at the time of sue grey's
report
since moscow is three or four hours
depending on time of year ahead
of london
why didn't they have it in the morning
um before sue gray's report was received
um or and just say we're terribly sorry
just as you they you mr putin can't make
it um
so in in your hours of darkness which is
different from ours um
we can't make it for reasons we don't
need to disclose
um
on monday afternoon and uh
monday evening um so
it is
aside from the humiliation
that he hasn't been able to uh do his
job as prime minister which is on
foreign policy talk to heads of
government uh it's just a reflection of
somebody just not having
not not getting the idea
that there could be a problem
uh and
and
the two two things won't work he can't
be in the house of commons and taking a
call from vladimir putin
sorry
um
how weary should we be about what's
happening on the border with ukraine
we should be
pretty worried i mean
it's very difficult to say whether
um
this will
the situation will result in a russian
invasion because i think russia realizes
that
the price of that in non-military terms
and maybe in military terms is going to
be very intense and um it had the
experience let me say look as the uk and
the us and others did as well of getting
bogged down in afghanistan
that was for 10 years
excuse me um
and will it want to get bogged down
again
so i
but uh i i mean i think
i'm
more optimistic than i was and indeed as
each day passes i think the
prospect of a russian invasion will
diminish but it's still there and it
depends on keeping the pressure up and
showing the ukrainians that we
that we are supporting them
okay um what's your advice to liz trust
she's got covered at the moment so she
can't head over to ukraine with the uh
prime minister she can't go to moscow
what sort of diplomacy can you carry out
from behind your desk
um
oh you can do quite a lot particularly
the crucial thing about
phone calls and these days zoom causing
and
team calls
uh in diplomacy is you need to have
built up
the relationships first
uh and it's not that much different from
normal human relations so
if she's got a good relations with uh
other foreign ministers um then she'll
be able to make the calls and sometimes
you have to make the calls and you've
never met the people in in your life
um but
i mean i think
liz should spend more time thinking
about the ukraine and rather less time
thinking about the next post she puts on
instagram uh
as part of her putative leadership bid
which i think for her
i say to it so they tried someone in
europe quite well uh as as well as the
country is a mistake
she says uh that the prime minister has
her wholehearted support and she has no
interest in being prime minister i know
people always say that uh i mean
it's it's um
uh
and
i mean the truth is that
boris johnson will have
liz trust his wholehearted support
until boris johnson is not there um and
um
well who knows in the secrecy of the
ballot
of the conservative parliamentary party
if there is a ballot how liz truss or
dominic robb
uh will vote but i'd have if i i mean i
watched dominic rob
face your very difficult questions and
give them
in a sense the best known answers he
could think of
but what the government's having to
think about
is that this is going to go on and on
and on
and every time anything
happens
whatever the subject is
they see will be
understandably shifting and shifted
by the journalists or by opposition mps
onto the prime minister's behavior i
mean i do not really i can't think
uh of
any other occasion in in my lifetime um
when a prime minister
has
faced this level of
destabilization of his own choosing
so and so whatever
boys john uh sorry dominic rabo let's
trust say about the fact that they will
give their prime minister full support
well they do for the time being
they will get more and more fed up with
this and it's not in my view going to go
away
um
it is
down to the uh backbenchers and his um
you know his other conservative
colleagues as well isn't it because
labour does not have a big enough uh
majority even uh with other flavors of
politics as well from the house of
commons and so it's up to the
conservatives uh to decide whether he
stays in power or not and it certainly
looks as though for now he still has
their backing what does that say about
the conservatives um to that side of the
house
well
the i i mean i think there are some i
mean i know there are very very many
perfectly decent conservatives uh
we we saw
examples of those in theresa may and
andrew mitchell
yesterday
who are absolutely appalled by this
um and i mean i'm not you know we have
lots of difficulties in government you
do including afghanistan and
above all iraq but i we've never had and
i've never sold on the other side i
didn't see it with margaret thatcher or
john major
or david cameron
this kind of
personal
failure of character which is eating
away
at the government
but um
so
i do apologize i was taken by my own
phrases and forgot your question
you know what that's happened to me
twice in two days now by former uh
foreign secretaries for the labour party
and i thought i was doing quite well i
was basically asking about the moral
fiber of conservatives on that side of
the house you don't want to get rid of
the leader what does it say about them
well they'll have to make their own
minds up about this about where their
interests lie um the crucial thing
everybody has to think about the house
of commons above all else is staying
there
how do you stay there i that means how
do you get reelected uh and you can't
take any seat for granted i mean we
found that
uh
uh
last at last the last election in
december 2019
um when
uh we lost catastrophically a number of
seats which frankly the labour party and
particularly awful
egregious jeremy corbyn had taken for
granted um and the conservatives will
find the same i mean back in 1997
um
we won
most of the seats in essex it's my home
county i know it very well
and they just the conservative seats
went down like flies and
so
and bear in mind that
since the uh conservatives have
only a handful of seats and like as we
do
in scotland there and and they're in a
minority in wales
they're
very very dependent for the majority of
what happens in english seats and in
in a lot of the so-called red wool seeds
we already know
that there is fury about the way in
which uh boris johnson has taken the
british public and the voters in those
areas for fools so
i think a few more weekends
where uh members of parliament
particularly new ones who've given mr
johnson his majority
getting their head scrubbed
by their voters may see a ship if it
doesn't
um they'll just tell me that the
conservatives have lost the will to
survive and i don't actually think
that's true
so why uh labor flailing at the polls
again
failing at the polls i probably missed
something this morning
uh yeah so the latest polls are
suggesting that the lead that uh labor
had has been cut in half in other words
i suppose the other way of looking at
that is that
people are either deciding that they
prefer boris johnson um to kia stammer
or they're
bored with the su grey story
well we're still ahead in the polls i
mean it would be a pretty surprising if
if we weren't um
they will bob up and down and i know one
says that when when
you you're below
the the other side in the in the polls i
personally uh think that kierstama has
done well and the public have been able
to
see
uh this man for the the man of values uh
that he is uh and compare and contrast
him
with mr johnson and i when we there'll
be a by-election
uh on thursday uh but that's to do with
the murder of sir david amis and i don't
think we'll get anything about of that
not least because
the main parties aren't standing there
um but i'm pretty optimistic about the
results of the may elections and if you
want we can have a side bet on that
and i'd love to come on the following
week and eat humble pie
[Laughter]
what do you make of what in blackford
got up to yesterday rules his rules you
know you can't expect the prime minister
to abide by rules and then the leader of
the snp
mr blackford is the kind of pantomime
character really oh no he isn't oh yes
he is
but did he do the right thing you know
he would say he's a man of conviction
yeah you can make a conviction point
without having to break the rules that's
my view i'm afraid i'm i've got a great
little time for the scottish national
party
nationalist party i mean they all
all things to all people provided
they're complaining
and pitching themselves
against the english and taking more
money
from english taxpayers
than english taxpayers get for
themselves and then complaining some
more
and one day
although it has been a very long time
coming and there's been a labor failure
in scotland um
the snp support will twist and fall
okay good to talk to you um thank you so
much for joining us again jack straw
always a pleasure thank you thank you
very much